I get it you look at me and you don't
think there's a man who cares a lot
about how he smells but you couldn't be
more wrong my friends I'm a fragrance
fella I'm a scent Soldier and thanks to
scentbird's new colorful cases
organizing my fragrances is easier than
ever scentbird is the subscription
cologne service my favorite scent is
East 12th by Ash by Ashley Benson I put
in this blue case so that when I go to
the theater to watch Kang take over the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I'm smelling
good baby when I'm really Kicking It Old
School and watching Return of the Jedi I
have this Brown scentbird case that
makes me party with the egg walks and do
the jub jub dance jab jab nub nub my
friends scentbird makes organizing your
fragrances easier than ever with their
scentbird colored cases if you want to
save money and smell good use code
rockstars 55 to save 55 off your first
month's order that's just seven bucks
for the month how do you organize your
fragrance collection by scentbird let me
know sound off in the comments